in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche bella find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape
with me in the studio is professor malik
washbush he's a psychiatrist at the
charity hospital here in berlin and he's
a specialist in the treatment of
depression hello professor welcome to
the show
what triggers depressions is it just a
conflict of unresolved inner conflicts
or external circumstances or is it just
in our genes
what we know nowadays it's that's a
combination of our genes so we become um
to earth
with a certain likelihood to get a
depression or not and that in
combination with um events in early life
would leads um to a depression or not
okay and who's especially at risk for
developing depression over a lifetime
and what is known nowadays is that um
the early life of this is very very
important so if you do have adverse
events there are traumatic experiences
this increases your risk for depression
and from a personality side it's those
people who are very faithful over care
for these other people who are at risk
for depression and and this is true
worldwide or are they any cultural
differences
it is known that there are cultural
differences on how depression looks like
with respect to the likelihood to get a
depression
it is worldwide the same phenomenon but
the how depression looks like is
different
but
it is finally the same disease worldwide
but suffering from depression is not
just being in a bad mood so how do you
actually diagnose depression as a
psychiatrist
depression is something which is as you
correctly stated more than bad mood it
is um if you suffer
every day for at least 14 days in bad
mood loss of interest sleep disturbances
loss of appetite and then one might
diagnose a depression and those are the
warning sides so the patient can say bye
bye themselves i'm depressed it is
individually very different what the
warning sites are so some patients say
tell us it's the sleep others says it's
the appetite loss of interest but these
are the key features of the depression
yes and sometimes the patients don't
even recognize that they are depressed
but friends maybe might recognize this
we got to view a question from aslan
popov from russia and and he wants to
know he's got a friend and he thinks
he's depressed the friend is depressed
but the friend doesn't want to go to see
a doctor
what can mr popov do
um so there's
stigmatization of depression is still
something which is worldwide present so
usually it is very very useful to take
symptoms out of depression which are
accepted such as sleep disturbances or
somatic syndromes and go with these
symptoms to a doctor
okay and who's the right doctor to go to
is it a psychiatrist or is it just a
normal gp family doctor um that's very
different worldwide so in germany it
would be a psychiatrist in regions where
psychiatrists are not so often present
it would be the general practitioner
and the world health organization
estimates that 350 million people
worldwide suffer from depression are the
numbers going up or is just the
diagnosis getting better
the numbers are going up because the
diagnosis are getting better so um
diagnosis is made more frequent more
often with increasing knowledge about
depression worldwide
and what about depression in in
childhood or in adolescence are they
going up as well
um the same phenomenon so so it is known
that
that
how depression looks like looks
different than in adults and that's the
reason why it's going up doctor we just
saw you in the report performing ect or
electroconvulsive therapy i must say
quite impressive but is this method not
dangerous
for dying brain cells
that is what is usually assumed that
that neurons brain cells are dying but
it is known that exactly the opposite
happens so
neurons new cells are born are newly
developed by by this treatment so it is
something which is completely opposite
of one what one would expect in
depressive so it's more protective to
the brain okay and is it effective
it is extremely effective so um
mainly eighty percent of every patient
treated with that treatment responds so
it is a quite high number of patients
who respond to that very good treatment
and do you think this could be
mainstream medicine one day
um one needs to perform a lot of afford
so two doctors involved two two nursing
staff so i would therefore not assume
that that would be mainstream but for
those patients where psychotherapy does
not work where medication does not have
effects for those patients ect would is
a wonderful alternative
and as a psychiatrist you're not using
electro compulsive therapy you're doing
research on using ketamine which is a
general anesthetic drug how is this
performed how is that working
um that's a quite new development in
anti-depressant treatment so what we
have observed there is that ketamine
works quite fast so
patients come out of the depression
within hours within 24 hours which is
unknown and very very new to us in an
exciting new research field
okay and the dangers of that method of
the ketamine method
so
it is an anesthesia it's quite safe
method
we have to select the right patients or
patient without hypertonia without any
heart diseases but for those patients
it's a safe treatment it what happens
from time to time is that patients get
delusions which are not wished but if we
select the right patients it's a quite
safe method okay for me as a gp i'm not
using electroconvulsive therapy i'm not
using ketamine i'm using drugs actually
so so what kind of patients are in the
need of drugs or just lifetime life
style changes when do i have to
prescribe pharmaceutical treatment
there are guidelines which say that the
first line treatment in moderate
depression is an anti-depressant these
are the patient for the drugs and the
main pillar of the treatment
if patients have a less severe
depression one might discuss whether
psychotherapy
should be used or medication but that's
something which we usually discuss
together with the patient and
prescribe that or perform that
which the patient wishes okay but and
what about lifestyle changes we got a
lot of viewer questions especially from
pakistan and with patients who want to
know um if sports can help in depression
yeah
in
depression which are not so severe sport
might be an effective treatment so
there's research going on at charity for
example which shows and indicates that
in
moderate depression depression of less
severity sport can be as effective as a
psychotherapy as a factor so
psychotherapy that's promising and and
what about prevention of depression are
there any methods that i can prevent
going into this mood
well we nowadays live in a world with a
number of difficulties which makes it
more likely to get a depression so
if you stand back from time to time and
if you stop being over careful that
might be a good way to prevent
depression great
dr bash bush thank you so much for being
in the studio with us
you